the highest scoring output Pyar Kiya to
game this season during the off-season
Raees reverses direct sense I stood this
with Andrew Wiggins hand off action with
Treveon Graham and the crossover move
left to right for Andrew Wiggins and
getting and sifting his way to the
basket Pascal gets caught with his hand
in the cookie jar buddy he's missed his
first 13 threes of the season for danzel
Russell that's not easy shot to hit Wow
[Music]
my goodness this is just [ __ ] Russian
we could go to work baby
she's very impressed it he was very
impressed with him in college and he has
not disappointed here the post
wicked spots Jake LaMotta state only
eight so they've been fouling and
they've been turning it over play
against I don't wonder because Andrew
you know his diet has changed - because
he's a vegetarian as good as Carlos in
the post you know he spends more time
[Applause]
karl-anthony towns the late cut by
injure wick Russell fainted twice third
time's the charm
and he knocks home the triple-t eight
points in this game a couple of fake
sticks with it Tim rolls and a little
bit of home I'm just surprised there
this game has been as sloppy as it has
was there they were on point this
morning that's a killer that's an
absolute killer
[Applause]
cool my wig let's just for the last
seven for the Warriors we get you talked
about in the clucks Todd Jim
one-possession game go he's got issues
setting the screen
so Russell just making
but if you set the 24 back to old days
that was a killer that's right here the
14 helps you Russell and a new
career-high for D'Angelo Russell Angela
Russell coming off the ball screen this
so switches and what he gonna do I mean
Carl's in his face it's grabbing his
hand look at the head holding hands
there
[Applause]
think about the Brooklyn game of the
Miami game he just restrict you reject
the screen you know if they're gonna
switch you don't want to drive right
back into the switch but using the
screen so he rejects it but Roberts is
out of position and rude his jets right
to the Roya
nice finish a couple of twenty-twos
going at it [ __ ] Glenn Robinson might
reach out and try to follow and you here
and you could have been called for a
following for this trying to strip break
the law every Wiggins is times you go
what the lake strip he had to earlier
that's better the chilling the basket
comes off the ball straight back
we'll pull back into the palette iris
made that famous
[Applause]
Russell no-look pass to cauley-stein
Russell Russell look at us changes 13
ties a forty nine point performance from
D'Angelo Russell broke hoes got three
blocks four steals of Kobe's got one
block two steals and Rochas got a bunch
of deflections as well
Kirsten Ross and Bryan Saunders have
managed Andrew Wiggins the confidence
that they've given him and the love that
they've shown him and to how much
confidence they have make a difference
because the Andrew Wiggins we've seen
he's paid them back right now with
clutch play and if Minnesota is able to
pull this game out just go and look up
go on nba.com look at the clutch stats
and look at growth Andrew Wiggins sits
with the Minnesota Timberwolves in
clutch moments he's been fantastic
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content